hut ab für unseren neuen verkehrs und
digital minister an die scheuer
der hat nämlich gerade eine handy-app
erfunden mit der man funklöcher melden
kann
funklöcher das ein großes problem ja vor
allem auf dem land vor allem auf dem
land aktuelle zahl wenn es um die
verfügbarkeit und schnelligkeit von
lte-netzen geht ist deutschland in
europa kein witz auf platz 32
hinter armenien ja aber einen platz vor
georgien yeah
botswana haus hat im sauerland
deutschlands dunkelstes funkloch
gefunden alles was ist hier das problem
anfang vom ende und so was alles wenn
man im wald ist ich bin ja auch im wald
macht finde ich dann notfall hat gehe
ich gerne anschluss weil ich hier noch
was hast du das für notfälle
ja wenn immer unterm baum komme wenn sie
mal einen baum
ich lebe ja ich habe ja noch hier und da
für mich eigenen holz und dann wenn ich
dann mal weg bin und fällt mir irgendwas
aber der baum auch sich feld wobei dann
nutzte empfangen auch nichts gelernt sie
haben ja hier kein internet was ich
totale wahnsinn findet das heißt sie
haben noch nie ihr mittagessen auf
instagram gepostet nein kann ich nicht
können sie etwas was macht man dann mit
dem mittagessen auf essen hat ja die
sensationelle idee ein app zu entwickeln
wo man funklöcher melden kann wenn man
unterwegs ist was ein bisschen ab so
dass wenn man in einem funkloch es kann
ja nix melden
deswegen können sie jetzt dass funkel
auch sozusagen in diese kamera
vielleicht melden dann kriegt man das
auch mit
ja hallo herr scheuerl ruhig da rein
hallo herr minister scheuer
wir möchten ein funkloch melden das ist
der ortsteil brennstoff aus der stadt
sundern vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
nachdruck vielleicht eine spur
verzweiflung dass der mann das ernst
nimmt ja vielleicht nehmen sie diesen
fall ja auch mal ernst
einige jahrzehnte darauf gewährleistung
und irgendwann musste es ja mal kommen
machen sie mal vor anja jetzt machen sie
mal endlich voran
wir warten schon lange die faust noch
mal das muss ja mal irgendwann
funktionierte
wissen sie warum ich sie ernsthaft
beneiden das interessiert jetzt dass sie
noch nie einen tweet von beatrix von
storch gelesen haben das macht sein wer
ist das das meint ich beneide sie so
sehr sie sich welche hält sie wie machen
sie das denn dann wird all ihre privaten
daten zu facebook schicken wollen zu
mark zuckerberg wie geht das ohne
internet muss man da aktenordner zur
post bringen
wie läuft das ja also die post hat er im
nachbardorf auch schon vor ein paar
jahren zugemacht ich durchgelaufen
[Musik]
da hält sich die laune eher in grenzen
ein glück dass es heute eine landkreis
tagung in wiesbaden gibt wo es unter
anderem auch um das thema
digitalisierung geht da bestelle ich
doch mal ganz liebe grüße aus brenzel
ich war gerade in brennstoffe was kann
ich den menschen sagen die wollen
irgendwas hoffnungsvolles hören was
können sie den menschen den brend
schritte versprechen wir werden
vorbeikommen vorbereiteten wird fix wir
müssen eine internet auch lebenslang
kabel legen und anschließen
na ja das haben wir ja vor ich brauche
eine positive botschaft für brennstoff
für was brennt
der ort der im funkloch lebt die politik
was tut ich will eine positive botschaft
den menschen nach hause bringen es darf
kein ort mehr im funkloch liegen kann
man mit fug und recht behaupten dass das
internet nicht zu deutschland gehört
noch nicht es gibt menschen die haben
nie internet und mobil empfangen die
leute in brenzel
also in brencher da gibt es gar kein
empfang 0 im sauerland liegt das was
kann ich den menschen an positive
botschaft jetzt mitbringen aus der
politik von mir von ihnen
ach es gibt ja einen koalitionsvertrag
der in berlin ausgehandelt wurde
den muss man lesen und wenn man daran
glaubt dass all das umgesetzt wird ist
das eine wunderbare botschaft verbrenne
ok brennt brennt ihr seid am arsch
[Musik]